dicht an dicht drängen sich dutzende
schweine in diesem stall
sie fressen sich teilweise gegenseitig
ohren und schwänze ab einige tiere
weisen riesige bäume auf offene wunden
und entzündete augen sind keine
seltenheit
schon kleine ferkel haben
verstümmelungen am ganzen körper
diese erschütternden bilder wurden jetzt
vom deutschen tierschutzbüro
veröffentlicht sie sollen vor wenigen
tagen in einem schweinemastbetrieb in
rheda wiedenbrück entstanden sein
in einem betrieb der unter anderem auch
die firma tennis beliefert die
aktionisten waren offenbar nachts in den
maststall eingedrungen das video zeigt
überfüllte stall buchten und schweine
die sich auf engstem raum
aneinanderreihen
inzwischen ermittelt die
staatsanwaltschaft bielefeld der kreis
gütersloh und auch die firma turniers
selbst gegen den mastbetrieb wir haben
den stall sofort überprüfen lassen so
sprecher andré fehlt städte gegenüber
bild wurde der schweinemäster sich nicht
äußern
angst davor dass fleisch schwer kranker
tiere auf den teller zu bekommen muss
der verbraucher laut der firma tönnies
nicht haben
nach der schlachtung werde jedes tote
tier von einem amtsveterinär begutachtet
tiere deren fleisch ungenießbar ist
wurden sofort aussortiert und entsorgt
so viele städte